[Music]
you're a man who likes to win that last
night was not an absolute victory for
you I'll be honest I thought it was a
very close to complete victory you just
cannot get you how to run the degree of
suffering that went down so the only
thing I think is to tell stories
personal story you know this thing about
if you can if you can't see it you can't
be it
graeme employment in film in this
country is 3% we're not seeing ourselves
in these key positions I think you can
inspire somebody who even is in the
model to be able to love themselves and
see that if we're confident in what we
feel they can be - never one to admit
defeat Donald Trump has framed his
party's election losses as a complete
victory tomorrow will be a new day in
America the words of Nancy Pelosi the
leader of the Democrats in the House of
Representatives as her party took
control of the house from the
Republicans Democratic Congress will
work for solutions that bring us
together when my status as an immigrant
black Muslim woman means that the
current administration
not see me as an American you know I
will not bow down the Republicans have
held the upper house including the seat
here in Texas when Ted Cruz fought off
the high profile challenge of 800 Rob
tonight is a victory for all the men and
women in this room and all the men and
women across this state that poured your
hearts your passion your time your
energy to rising to defend Texas if the
midterm elections were a referendum on
Donald Trump and the president seems
pretty happy with the result
calling the night a tremendous success
[Music]
okay yeah go ahead go ahead go ahead
Thank You mr. president
Cordelia Lynch Sky News you're a man who
likes to win but last night was not an
absolute victory for you beyond it I'll
be honest I thought it was a I thought
it was a very close to complete victory
when you look at it from the standpoint
of negotiation when you look at it from
the standpoint of deal-making because
it's all about deal-making again if we
had the majority and we had one or two
or three votes to play with we would
never we would have been at a standstill
I really believe that we have a chance
to get along very well with the
Democrats and if that's the case we can
do a tremendous amount of legislation
and get it approved by both parties so I
consider it to be hey look I won Georgia
President Obama campaigned very hard in
Georgia Oprah Winfrey campaigned very
very hard all over the television I said
this is going to be tough I only had me
I didn't have anybody else and I went to
Georgia and we had one of the largest
crowds that anybody here has seen ever
at a political rally and you know what
he won anyone actually by a pretty good
margin he won I think it was a great
victory I'll be honest I think it was a
great victory and actually some of the
news this morning was that it was in
fact a great victory but if you look at
it from the standpoint of gridlock
I really believe there's going to be
much less gridlock because of the way
this is going than any other
kelly-ann how much more difficult to
expect things to get with a Democrats
house that's really a question for the
Democrats because the president is the
ultimate deal maker a negotiator he has
proven even in the first years with
Republican rule here in Washington that
he's been willing to do tails of the
Democrats he signed into law very
recently in historic Oakley legislative
law that had the support of every single
Democrat in the House and Senate he also
was willing to make a deal almost a year
ago and on the so-called dreamers
Democrats walked away from the table the
that the Congress needs to act and if
Nancy Pelosi and the Democrats in
Congress spent all their time on the
Pietschmann investigation subpoenas
they'll be held to account from their
voters they will basically hand the
election and the election of Donald
Trump in 2020 if they do that so they're
calling for unity they need to go first
they need to present to the president
their proposals their ideas and he will
he will consider them like he does
everything else can tell you about the
incredible true story of a detective who
chose to you're up dicover for 20 years
posing as a pedophile in James
subsequently saved dozens of children
from abuse and sent to prison many who
were a danger to society it's very
difficult to to actually comprehend and
understand how you can actually engage
and work with these individuals you have
to break down a lot of barriers to be
sort of accepted by them because
everything that you're doing is totally
against you as a human being I'm the
parent with two young children and hi
I've got tonight go through certain
barriers so I've got to deal with images
I've got to look at images because if
you can't deal with looking at an image
then you put a child at risk you
potentially put yourself at risk so on
top of that you've then got to say right
I've got to talk
sexually about the image I've got a
plausible you've got to be plausible
because they'll expect to analyze
everything that you do were you able to
go home at the end of the day for want
of a better word and put it in a box and
it not seep into your normal life you've
got to have very good support mechanisms
around you because this is unique very
many people very few people do it my
wife was the extremely supportive fully
understood well
doing so that was great within the
family circle I had a fantastic
psychologist who was looking after me
and my managers were were very very
supportive and you need that because
it's a long process I should imagine
every year you thought to yourself why
on earth am i doing this I've done this
too long but the problem I imagine
becomes the longer you do it the more
useful you are to the operation more
indispensable you become yeah I think a
very good friend of mine said to me well
if you can save one child then you've
achieved quite a lot I do say if you
think um I probably read about 50
probably and you know undercover police
things had a bad rep in recent years
hasn't it but yes you can point to the
fact you've saved lives
by being an undercover police officer
yeah I'm proud of what I've done and
there are many officers out there who
have done undercover work in various
fields and they and they've made a
difference and they're very and they're
themselves would be proud I have a duty
of care to children and ultimately
whatever happens in an operation the
child comes first and that's the most
important
as darkness falls a traditional call to
remembrance echoes over
thousand-year-old stones but then yeoman
warders join a cadet a veteran and a
serving soldier in lighting thousands of
lamps around the moat of the Tower of
London those who make the tower their
home say the moat is a special place I
thought that is song because this is
such a hollow piece of ground that moat
is where their lot of guys came swore
allegiance for the first world war two
before they went to front got kitted out
got trained here
and most those guys didn't come back
I just throw it in some small way if we
could just bring them back just once
more just to lay them on the ground of
this country once more is something
really worth in this unique and poignant
spectacle is the culmination of five
years work by the artist Rob hurt who
spent 15,000 hours and making seventy
two thousand three hundred and
ninety-six shrouded figures it was just
about physical izing that number and
creating a figure for every one of those
names and it was so important that it
was actually each figure is associated
with a name as I would as I make a
figure it would be crossed off cost of
great volumes of books I've got and that
was so vitally important that these that
these weren't just a collection of of
images they are actually representing an
individual this is where I store some of
the figures and this is where I've
worked for several years down here which
is it's it's quite quite a place it
really is it's amazing to be in their
company some odd thing to say but it as
a sense of perspective it's like it's
like nothing else I always read the name
aloud when I cross it off I always read
the name aloud which is important just
for one more time it's very overwhelming
being
in here yeah it gets me every time
remembrance has to be personal I think
this is where the trouble with
remembrance is it is yes we have these
important symbols they are important and
we have the figures you know we know how
many millions of people died on British
like the French side the German side
it's what they taught in the history
classroom exactly only now and the
millions came over from India from
Africa this was a world war it's enough
to say if there's a world war for a
young for anyone you can't get your head
round there you just cannot get your
head around the degree of suffering that
went on so the only thing I think is is
to tell the stories personal stories now
they can be true it can be about your
great uncle your great great-grandfather
or you can do what I do
gives you bases on trees and then take
it a stage further and you make
fictional it and there's a different
kind of truth in fiction and what's good
about that is the child can then
identify with the soldier because
otherwise all those soldiers out there
now and they will come anyone who knows
them well news them is gone as well so
effectively they're all unknown soldiers
now the all unknown soldiers so the only
way to get to know one is to know a
story what does the poppy mean to you my
uncle Peter was killed at age 21 in the
RAF in the Second World War so to me he
was a photograph on a mantelpiece
nothing wrong and but you know when
you're young and you see your mother cry
will you don't forget it and and my
mother was not a crying woman generally
a talk but on November the 11th and on
uncle Peters birthday she was beside
herself with grief and was like that
till the end of her life so what did I
learn from that I learned that this man
young man he was 21 he was an actor and
I did it strapped thought he was just
whole life ahead of him never became a
father never became a grandfather like
me like a great grandfather I mean he
didn't have this chance to fulfill
himself and that touches me really
touches me so when I put a puppy on a
memorial as I did yesterday in my
village he's the person I think of so
we've in a sense I was awful but we are
lucky at least we at least we can
connect to that war it's very hard for
children growing up today to whom war is
still it's mostly now an image on
on film and thank God we are not in a
world where we have horrible vicious
little walls going on all over the place
but to kids it's something on you know
it's on your tablet and you you look at
it and then you know you watch The
Simpsons it goes from one to the other
it's not their fault we do the same
thing it's too painful to watch but if
it's someone you know
then you remember so it connects up I
think with your previous question I
think I think we just have to find our
own unknown soldier' Lenny Henry and
Meera Syal are among those who presented
a letter to number 10 Downing Street
asking for tax breaks for the film and
TV industry to address a diversity
crisis signatories include Thandie
Newton and Adrian Lester and the letter
argues and an increase in employment of
women disabled people and people from
black Asian and minority ethnic
backgrounds behind the camera is crucial
there are several fronts being fought at
the moment and I think what's great is
we're in a position where people are
genuinely interested in making change
they haven't gotten the ideas
particularly I mean we've we've worked
out that tax breaks would be a good
thing because we've seen happen in
Chicago and there are other states now
following maybe New York State will
follow tax relief for diversity in film
and television we think it's a good idea
somebody else should work out the
details but you know we're already via
the BFI and verse of the people giving
tax breaks for things that are British
British subject matter British cast
British production and it will be a
fantastic thing to give tax breaks tax
relief for diversity more women more
people of color people with disability
because the figures as they stand in our
industry are still appalling and it
needs to be changed and I think the more
we talk about it there's more everybody
can see that more things are transparent
and everything's out there everybody can
see or this is obviously a problem
things need to be done I mean there's
you know barely employment in film in
this country is 3 percent so 3 percent
of the people that work on films and
television
country or black Asian minority ethnic
you know when you consider that places
like London for instance is 40 percent
be AME that's a really lopsided figure
working in film there are thirteen point
six percent women directors working a
film in this country on something like
EastEnders women directors are one
percent eme directors are one percent
sorry and noir point three percent of
the working film industry are people
with disabilities so you know this thing
about if you can if you can't see it you
can't be it
we're not seeing ourselves in these key
positions there are many eme producers
out there who are more than capable of
commissioning more than capable of green
lighting things more than capable of
looking at things go that's good you
know let's find that writer that's good
let's hire that production designer more
than capable and they've hit a wall that
hits a ceiling and we need to start
thinking of ways of dismantling those
walls and ceilings how do we make it
easier for more women to be in the
industry more people with disability
more pame how do we make it a bit easier
so that it's not just a struggle you
know people in a lot of production
companies and a lot of broadcasters oh
you're pushing against an open door we
want to do this this is something what
to do if the door is open why are we
still pushing
when you think of oh I don't know
lingerie models you tend to imagine the
Victoria's Secret Angels resplendent
with feathers and diamonds and a size 8
or smaller yep according to official
data the average woman in the UK is a
dress size 16 and wears a size 36 double
D bra 89% of women don't feel
represented in mainstream fashion now
the company simply B is hoping to change
attitudes with a catwalk parade
featuring models of all shapes and sizes
the inclusive event is called we're all
angels and it comes two days ahead of
the annual Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show
we're leaps and bounds to where we were
five years ago if you think about it
it's all about the steps of the brand's
take and the risks and I think that's
why today was so important it's about
being able to showcase different sizes
so we had sizes from 10 you know they go
from size 10 to 32 but I believe we had
sizes from 10 all the way up to 22 today
so it's one of those things where you
get to see different body types with the
same brand being able to be inclusive in
one and showing that we all look sexy
and confident and that you can't have
that I think it inspires somebody who
even is in a model to be able to love
themselves and see that if we're
confident in what we feel they can be to
Itoko it often makes me insane and
voicing their opinion that they feel bad
or they don't love their body to take a
break when they need to and look at the
world without a filter and that's what I
you know I said I was quoted recently
saying I want cellulite on a catwalk
because everyone really does have it
even ballerinas have it or Serena
Williams has it and it we've made it
this really you know infamous bad thing
to have but it's just it's a part of our
human bodies so I don't see the qualms
and using unretouched photos I think I'm
all for showing who you are
and I think the more of us do it the
more we want of it now the author
Jacqueline Wilson has never shied away
from tackling some of society's harshest
realities she's written more than a
hundred stories discussing everything
from divorce alcoholism suicides and of
course the care system inhabited by her
famous character Tracy Beaker with her
latest novel she brings her most loved
character back to life i sat down to
talk to her about the launch of her new
book my mum Tracy Beaker Tracy is a
child was a child say in children's home
desperate to be fostered and I got the
original idea because I saw some photos
of real children who and there was a
special campaign to try and get foster
parents for them and I couldn't help
wondering what must it feel like to be
in this situation I didn't really think
it would be a particular success here
other books as well they've never really
shied away from the harsh realities of
life you've been very upfront and honest
with your readers some of whom are as
young as eight years old you've covered
subjects like abandonment divorce
alcoholism poverty depression suicide
and of course the care system it's
interesting because how do you find the
tone and the language to speak to
children because these are some subjects
that their parents will find it
difficult anything violent anything too
upsetting is off off the page it's
happened and it will be mentioned but I
would hate to traumatize any child it's
very very difficult because children
nowadays when they watch television or
they look at things on YouTube they they
are far more aware than perhaps adults
realized what do you think children
worry about today in 2018 what you think
their main concerns are because you're
all about putting yourself in the
mindset of the child there are lots of
anguished emails I get from you know
somebody's friend has gone off with
somebody else I think they're far more
worried about the way they look now and
they're worried about bullying
it's the sort of thing that you know an
iris a child a dystopian novel would be
all about a way that children young
people their minds are being manipulated
and now in in a sometimes benign way I
think that just happening you're back
into the groove now with Tracy Beaker
you wouldn't commit to his Secor when I
spoke to you about it a little earlier
but now there are so many new themes to
explore and Tracy is an adult dealing
with different issues are you tempted I
am tempted because I have been talking
to quite a lot of people about my mom
Tracy Beaker and many people have said
we'll come on what does happen next
adjacent Tracy so I'm thinking about it
but certainly it won't be the next book
because that's already written and
that's something else entirely
but I Tracy is there in my head still so
is Jess I I don't think they're going to
go away
[Music]
just comin how do you feel about Brick
City be advised in state so now I've
shown my way into the Treasury do you
have any advice for the Prime Minister
about the way things go I'm on my way to
the Treasury for this of what she's
doing what I let again get her let her
get on with the job
[Applause]
[Music]